Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 12th, 2017. What's going on now? Why Ya? Um,
and I know what you're thinking. Yeah. You're probably saying, hey,
what do you mean is time for the Monday morning podcast bill? It's so late.
What the fuck? Um, it's like this week.
What a year. You're never late.
He though he had gas show up in your wife's like,
no, we were waiting. Well, it's all right.
Called Dao. You know,
you want to look at her the way Vince spic man looked at that guy in the sports
show and go, oh, fucking slap a piece of paper out of her hand.
But you can't because all your relatives are there watching.
So then you got to sit there and make excuses. Oh, the, uh,
the street like down the street was busted.
So it was just blanket red or blinking, you know, yellow.
So it was real slow and there was water coming out of the sewers.
And, uh, some guy, I can't believe it's some guy in a hang glider squared,
a Canda God hand to God.
He got blown off course and he, yeah, he landed on right,
right on the side of the supermarket. Yeah. Hit the side of it.
He went down in the boat.
Why can't you just admit you were late? Because you don't care about me.
It's not that I don't care about you,
it's just I just don't give a shit about this.
And I thought maybe if I showed up a little later than it'd be less minutes.
I'd have to spend at this. Yeah.
Are you saying you don't like by relatives?
Yes. No, I'm kidding. You know what I'm saying?
Um, God forbid any of my relatives listen to this. I like all my relatives.
I got lucky. I came from,
I came from a cool family and I married into a cool family.
You know what I mean? So there you go. Now I might just covering my bases.
Nobody knows. Why can't I get the fucking Internet here? I don't, you know why?
Cause I spend 9 million. I'm going to, I'm like this, do you know what I see?
I still have cable, I have a dish, whatever.
And I get all the packages and I know at this point you have these cord cutters.
They just cut the cord and they there they saying Fuck Network TV,
fuck 60 minutes, fuck all of that shit. Um,
I guess it's all just gonna end up on the computer and just every TV show is
gonna have an app or every network is going to have an app within the app will
be all the shows.
I'm sure that already exists cause I know there's HBO hot take or online or
streaming now. Whatever the fuck it's called, summer slam, showtime,
Summer Slam, whatever the fuck that call calling it.
So I'm old school and the reason why I'm old schools now cause I'm down to earth
man,
it's because I do not want to waste one second of my fucking life trying to
figure how the new shit works. All right.
That's the reason
I've always bought cars and I drive them for a decade.
I just keep changing the fucking oil. That's what I do.
The only reason why I went from the Prius to the Jag is just because my daughter
was coming and I was just like,
I bet buy a cool car before she gets here or I'm going to be fucked.
And I never bought myself a cool car because I don't know,
I've always been a frugal son of a bitch, you know,
I didn't want that stupid fuck.
You know when I was drive down the street with your whole fucking cool ass car
and everybody turned around and looking at you,
I like blending in the background, you know, leave me alone. Dive Bar,
dive bar garden.
I not VIP that down there at the fucking Sushi restaurant where all the fucking
cons hang out with the cameras, you know,
whatever that fucking show is. So anyways, you know I had,
I had like a really bad cab driver back from lax.
I take cabs cause I'm not downloading that fucking app onto my phone and then
you track me and see where the fuck I am. Those Uber cuts. All right,
fuck them. So yeah, I just take the taxi.
So I get in the cab and we're driving egos. How do you want to go? I go,
let's take the fucking highways, right? It's the middle of the day here.
So you know, I always pick out the windows,
we come into land to see what the old fluoro fizzy looks like. And um,
so whatever we get on the goddamn thing.
And I noticed the guys not in the Hov Lane, I'm like, buddy,
there's two of us here we are the world we're saving.
We're thinking locally and acting globally, right? This is green piece here.
We have two people in a car. We get to use the diamond lane. And he's like,
oh no, I dog the,
he didn't have the easy pass thing, whatever it is. And I'm like,
how come we don't have that? And he goes, well,
it costs money and his accent costs money.
What does your fucking job is driving people around you asshole.
If you had that thing you could get people to and from where they're going and
you could, you could pick up more people, right? You could make more money.
So I'm in the back, you know, big Hollywood phony,
getting all grumpy trial. Look at, look at, look at bill. Oh look at him.
He's getting in a taxi cab. He didn't forget where he came from.
Two seconds later,
I'm fucking bitching out this fucking poor old baster
in my own passive aggressive way.
Just mumble in the backseat out of fucking out of the fucking day.
This is what the fuck. I mean this is on May. Should I,
he should have said that as you pulled up or whatever. Right.
So then he just had no instincts. You know, we go to get off our exit, you know,
onto another fucking highway. So there's long line
that all this shitheads weighed in and then there's Surrey Ray Ray Liotta light,
right?
Fuck you pay me going in through the kitchen.
People work nine to five. That was fish nooks, right?
We didn't ask for anything we want wanted, we just, we just took it.
And then when it was all said and done, your busted joint out, right?
You take that fuck.
You go around everybody like you still going straight in the last seconds you
put on your right hand directional, you get in,
somebody beeps at you who gives a shit and there you are. All right.
Those are basic skills that a cab drivers should have.
And he gets in to the fucking soccer mom line and I was just like,
this guy is the worst. And I was just like, you know what? He's an old man.
He drives a capital. Okay, who gives a fuck?
So then I just said, you know what? Who gives a fuck? So then he goes,
which way do you want me to go? Which highway? I go, does it even matter?
At this point? It's like you're going to sit in the longest.
I didn't say this part in and sit in the longest line.
You don't have the fucking Hov thing. I mean
you want to just pull over and get some lunch. Let me, I will fuck a Gonia.
So anyways, we get up to that. My house, he goes, I pay paying,
I say credit card. So he takes my credit card and he does the whole thing,
reaching through the little fucking divider window there,
and then he hits no tip and I go too wide. You hit no tip. He goes,
he goes, Nah, I don't know that thing. He goes,
I deserve to be punished. That's what he said. And I said, Jesus Christ,
I'm not taking it to that level. I was upset half an hour.
I'm going to fucking tip you. He goes, Nah, I don't deserve above a plan.
I got off. Don't find them. Just made me sad. Don't ever say that.
So an IBM 20 bucks cash and he's all fucking mean.
I'll get you changed it, change you.
When is this how you do it? Maybe that's his scam.
He doesn't have the thing.
And then in the end he fucking just puts his head down and goes, oh,
I don't deserve a tip. And then a fucking soft. He goes, no, yes you do.
And then he gets $20 tip.
Even though he stuck at what he was doing and he still doesn't have to pay for
the thing. I think, you know what? I think I got, I think I got a scamp.
I think I fell for it. I think I bought, I bought a a, you know,
a VCR and I open it up and it's just a brick in the box. Remember that one?
That was the old scam back in the 80s. It kid,
you want to VCR 50 bucks the fucking Hannity and you've run away with the box.
You open it up. There was a brick and then
brilliant, brilliant fucking scam. You know,
cause even if they asked to open up the box, you know what's in there.
So all you gotta do is as they go to open it,
you just grab the brick before they do and you smash him over the head.
Then you take everything in his wallet, sort
of fail sick, you know, unless the guy's bigger than you.
Then as he goes to open, he just go, cops, cops, cops,
and you grabbed the box and you get the fuck out of the,
I don't know what I'm talking about. So anyways, I had a great weekend. Um,
I went up to the, uh,
I went up to Montreal Morial with Sir Paul Versey and,
uh, Andrew Feminists. And, uh,
we did the Olympic theater on my birthday Saturday night and he probably wanted
to, hey, bill, why did you, why would you do stand up on your birthday?
It's cause I wanted to go to the Formula One Formula One race on June 11th.
And when I booked it, I wasn't thinking June 10th is my birthday.
I just saw June 11th. And that's not an important day to me. You know,
that's how dumb I am.
It didn't dawn on me that my birthday was the fucking day before. So anyways,
I go up there and um, I go out, when Andrew brought me up,
he goes, uh, keep it going for the birthday boy.
And he brought me out and the crowd sang me happy birthday was awesome,
had a fun show.
I get off stage and I walked down to the green room and um,
some people from Jess for were there and they had got me this,
this unbelievable cured meat from someplace with bread.
And they had all like the a, what's that Kid's movie? Um,
you know, the car is talk, what does that, is it called cars?
I Dunno, I don't, you know, I just, I'm new to the kid game, whatever.
So they had those all up there.
Like I was a five-year-old and then my lady had sent me up a bottle of Johnny
Walker blue, which is funny cause I was trying to be Billy, no fun.
And I was telling her how great I felt,
not drinking and getting eight hours sleep and I'm talking about my birthday.
And she goes, Hey Jada, have a couple tonight. You have a couple tonight.
And I was like, yeah, why do you always do this to me?
I'm trying to do the right thing.
They're trying to go to bed early and you're always like, Bill,
you're not an alcoholic. Stop being so dramatic. You know?
And then I realized, oh it's cause she got me the journey of our complaints.
I called her up and then she, you know, we had a good laugh about that.
So I had a little shot of that before I did.
The second show and then the second show at the end of that Versie in Jemilla's
brought out a cake with candles on it and shit.
And everyone was singing happy birthday again. It's a 1400 cedar.
I had 2,800 people and people didn't like my act towards the end sing the happy
birthday was one of the best parties I've ever had. So I'm an asshole.
I go to blow out the candles and I go, I gotta make a wish.
I gotta make a wish and I'm in Montreal. I go,
I wish for a Bruin Stanley Cup championship next year. They're all like,
okay.
Well it was funny though.
It was their reaction made me laugh when I blew out part of the candles without
the rest of them. So I guess not winning next year, but a,
I really want to thank everybody that came out. I had such a fucking great time,
both shows and that really is one of the great cities,
um, that I've ever been to. I love that place.
I wish I had more time to spend there, but, um, you know,
I kind of flew up and, uh,
I was just tired from that whole week of hour running around running my yap
promoting the show.
So I just sorta went into the fetal position before the show.
I didn't even get to walk around and see anything.
Then I did the two shows and uh,
then I went right back to bed,
went right to bed and got eight hours sleep and then woke up and went to my
first Formula One race,
which I have to tell you lived up to the hype.
Um,
I don't even know where to begin as far as like going out to just see seeing
this event that I don't even know what like a year and a half ago I,
I sorta knew the sport existed. I mean, I knew about it, but I wasn't,
you know, doing all this shit of be,
we know watching every single race. So now to finally show up,
you know what that going on was like a,
I don't know how to explain it. Like the cars stems.
Just seeing the cars alone was like seeing a celebrity to me, like all that.
So Ferrari, that's, that's the fucking, that's number Sadie's team. Ah,
there's the fuel shot, the four Sindia team, you know,
it was incorrect. It was just an incredible experience. We get there, we,
you know, we park, then you take a little boat over and um,
I don't know. It was crazy. You know though,
the guy who does all the wrap up shit, you know, the,
the interviews and everything before and after a will bucks and he came out to
the show, he was telling us she got to come down to the pit area,
whatever the fuck they call it, the, uh, I forget what the fuck they call,
but we had these sick ass passes and we had just under a Illuminati level seats,
you know,
every time you think you're in the best place you could watch and you find out
there's another more air condition to area with even older manicured look at
dudes with the younger, hotter looking chicks.
Every time you think you're at the yet,
the final level of Dante's inferno, there's another fucking level.
It's incredible. You know, there was a hole,
there was one other level above where the hell we were at. And uh,
that's where the guys look like a,
you know what Celine Dion's husband used to look like?
You know that guy m he was a ball dude.
He basically look like Rob Reiner,
but he was the fucking shape shifts shift or like lizard level,
you know, one of those guys that always dresses all in white,
like he's a bald dude, but even like just the Shitty ad left on this side,
you like, that's like a fucking thousand dollar haircut.
His beard was like perfectly manicured. You know what I mean?
Those guys, those guys who was like,
their whole wardrobe is like linen and they take, yeah,
they walk around like in Christ clothes.
Okay.
They're always on the French Riviera. They're always in a fucking yacht.
They got private jets and then there's always some mere cat looking chick
sitting next to them that's like fucking like, you know,
2122 and you're like, oh my God,
did you pull up and you're fucking world cups sailboat,
you know, go into a town and just walk up to these broke people just, you know,
genetic, you know,
they hit the lottery genetics and had this beautiful girl and you just took her
away, you know?
Do you open toed fucking sandals?
Yeah,
I remember that guy. Celine Dion's husband. I just remember he,
not only was he Barb, but his head was perfectly tan,
so it didn't even look bad.
And then he just had this angelic white hair on this side.
Same thing with like the a his beard.
Okay.
It was a different kind of white, you know, like the, you know,
like those fancy fucking paint you can get with.
It's just a hint of another color in there. I don't know what was in there,
but you can see why.
So Celine was just so in love that she was punching herself in the fucking chest
every night. Couldn't get wait to get back.
Okay.
I mean,
if that's what is fucking hair and then side of his head and his beard looking
at, can you imagine this guy's pubes I must see he had a leg up,
right?
Perfectly Tan junk. You know what,
this fucking angelic winged pubes I can't even imagine that. That,
yeah, we didn't get to that level.
We got to the level where it was a bunch of people,
like just fucking real race fans.
We got to the level that we had a canopy and I still got a fucking sunburn.
That's how white I am. You know, cause the sun wasn't on my head,
but it hit my fucking chest. So got all fucking red and um,
but I want to thank everybody at the f one race. Everyone was so fucking cool.
So long story short, I got to make it funny man. I had such a good time.
So we're sitting like if you watch a replay of the race when,
right when the, they come out of the pit, you know, to rejoin the race,
right? Where they hit the acceleration, you know,
they gotta drive like fucking two and a half miles an hour and then they get to
this point where they can fucking take off, right, right.
Where they take off was where we were sitting and um,
we could see turn one and then turn two and
um,
it's a whole other game trying to watch the race.
Um,
when you're there, if you don't have like, I mean,
I wish I brought like a radio so I could have figured out what the fuck was
going on because I didn't know what happened to Vettel.
I didn't know that the red bull guy, you know, who was it? Uh,
Max a Max Maximilian there, a max for stabbing. Right.
He clipped the front of his car. I had no idea what was going.
All I know is he pitted really early and I was like, what the fuck?
And all of a sudden he went from second place to like 15th or last in the race.
So I kind of knew, but I had no, I had no idea what happened.
I didn't know that, that fucking, uh, what's his face there? Kimmy? Raking in.
I didn't know that he had problems with his brakes. We had no fucking idea.
No idea. Um,
okay.
And uh, it was so fucking loud yet. Earplugs in and the guy's talking over,
but it's just so God damn loud. Um, I'm jumping all over the story of do,
we took a little boat over,
we parked in the garage and then you get in this little boat,
takes you over there and then we'll hook this up down in the whole fucking
whatever the fuck they call it because of the P and we got to look at the
garages and all that shit in and we went into the red bull one.
Okay.
In me, very busy and families got to meet, uh, Daniel Ricardo,
who I famously called a Rick, Ricky, Rick and in or some shit. Daniel, Ricardo,
nicest fucking guy ever. And by the way,
I want to be in the shape of an f one driver. This guy's a fucking ridiculous.
This guy was like, uh, I dunno, he's like five 11. So he's got me by an inch,
so he was probably 30 pounds lighter than me.
It's fucking amazing. And he goes, yeah,
we get weighed twice a day right before the, you know,
during the race week or whatever it was joking about some fucking broccoli thing
that drink.
He just drank and how much weight they lose when they're in the car and all that
type of stuff. Um, I really want to thank red bull racing, how far,
how cool and nice they were and everything. Uh,
they were kind of the exact opposite of this fucking count.
We met from the Ferrari team.
Granted it was after the race and I thought he was one of the guys was cool.
He was really, really nice. But the first guy we met was a con,
but I think he thought we will be in contact because I didn't understand.
I knew that Ferrari was having a nightmare of a day,
but I didn't realize the level. I mean, I thought it was so cool that, you know,
Vito was able to work his way back up to the field.
I was kind of paying attention to him. I wasn't paying attention to Kimmy.
So when I went down there, I, you know, I didn't know what to say.
The guy was like, after the race,
all this Ferrari guys are like smoking cigarettes too. It's fucking hilarious.
All tanned up fucking smoking cigarettes.
And I just walked up and I was just like,
like a,
I was just like, hey man, is it okay confers,
he gets a picture with you cause you wanted a picture with somebody from
Ferrari, you know, he's half Sicilian, you know,
so the guy's just leave. He's like, yeah, yeah. And I said, hey, you know,
you know, good race today. You know, you, you guys,
at least you got by the forced India guys and his face just dropped
and [inaudible]
I swear to God in his face,
I understood the entire history and the pressure of working on Ferrari.
Like he, he just looked at us. I can't even,
he didn't say anything and then he just went, uh, I said, ugh.
And I was trying to make it nice again. I was,
I told Nate a good race when they had a terrific race.
He probably thought he didn't know this was my first event,
so he probably thought I was fuck with them. So he's probably not a cunt,
but if you could have seen this guy's face, fucking drop it.
I'll tell you if an actor ever did with this, guys faced it in a movie,
you'd win an Oscar and now versus he's got to stand next to him and verse.
He can read people better than me. You know, he's half Sicilian, half Greek.
It's fucking over, right. So he feels uncomfortable.
So I'm trying to make it nice going, like, all right,
this is going to be a legendary picture, whatever.
And then he goes on and he takes a picture and then the fucking, the guy,
we thought it was a con, but probably thought we were a con. He goes, no,
you just missed the legend. Go by Michael. He goes out Vettel that'll just walk,
bike. We're like, really? Where do you go? He goes,
I went right in there and we believed them.
And then Andrew figured out later that he was just fucking with us.
Okay.
Um, and then we met somebody else in the Fryer team, which, who's really nice,
but um, anyways, it was a, uh,
it was just an amazing fucking time. I don't even know. I don't know.
I don't know how to do it justice. It's too, it was too much to try to,
okay.
Pull it all into,
I guess I started at the fucking middle and then went back to the beginning and
then I went to the end of the fucking race.
Just know in the end we were sitting outside of a Lewis Hamilton's garage,
you know,
after everybody left and there was all these fans there and they introduced the
whole team. The crowd goes crazy, like racing's really big with the fence.
Like they do all this extra stuff, they're great.
So then they would chant Louis his name and Louis comes out again with another
bottle of champagne.
He sprays it on his team and then sort of whipped around in our direction.
And we actually got hit with the champagne from Lewis Hamilton.
That's how fucking close we were.
So I don't know how to ever top that experience. But like I'd like to say again,
thank you to everybody who, uh, you know,
Bruce Hills and all those guys from just for last, for hooking us up.
We had a great time and um, yeah, I don't know what to tell you,
but I kind of realized just going through,
talking to everybody in like the garages and Shit, just how
it's like Mercedes won't give red bull,
they try to buy an engine I guess from Mercedes and they're like, yeah,
no we're not giving you that. Basically.
Cause Daniel Ricardo's too good of a fucking driver.
We don't need that competition. However,
they will sell it to other fucking teams. Like I think force India,
they gave them, but it's not the same Mercedes engine that they have.
It's really fucking weird. Like it's like, all right,
well we'll sell an engine to a team that we know we could beat so we can make
the money and help pay for the fucking team,
but we're not gonna give it to a good team.
Okay.
But I don't get how like red bull when,
when what's his face? Uh,
Vettel was driving for one like fucking three in a row.
Four in a row and nobody could catch him. It's like, what?
What, what,
what the fuck happened to red bull's engine over the last four years? You know,
I don't know.
I got my fucking program here and I hope I'm not boring you guys to shit.
I'm going to get off this quickly because I know that for me to start talking
about driving for fucking 20,
God damn well at that taxi one was a taxi was a nice mainstream story,
wasn't it? Doesn't that count for anything? You fucking assholes? Um,
no. If I look up the Mercedes team,
they've only been around since, uh,
2010. Now.
I know Mercedes has been racing cars since the 1950s.
Like I don't get out of the Ferrari team's been around since 1950.
Is this like some AMG shit?
I'm going to have to look up the history of these teams because I found it
fascinating because after a while I was like, you know what?
I'm not going to root for Mercedes and fucking,
I'm not going to join this sport.
And then drew for the fucking Yankees or red socks easy. Right.
So I kind of like a, I like red bull and I like fucking, uh,
force India just cause I had a great time when I did that Gig in Mumbai and the
comedians over there will fucking hilarious breaking balls and stuff. But um,
but then I saw the owner of the team or wherever the director is,
it's just some fucking white dude for Cindia.
Is there like a fucking Aziz looking dude anywhere in there that's fucking,
you know,
you figured with the name like that there's gotta be an Indian Dude,
you know, I don't fucking know. Anyways,
what am I talking about here? Um, so I had added yeah, every fucking time.
How about that? I'll leave it at that. I'll leave it at that.
And what's his face? Lewis Hamilton got 25 fucking points and uh,
now he's only, what, like 12 behind, he was 25 behind.
That was the one exciting thing was watching Vettel work his way through the
field. Oh and I forgot to say all the fucking, the four Sandia guys,
even if you're not into this sport, ah,
they were going back and forth with one another, right?
The young kid was trying to get through and the Perez guy wouldn't let him
through, would not let him throw up, right. What's the other guy's name? Oh,
[inaudible] wanted to get through and he wouldn't get them through.
So while they were fighting with each other,
right in fourth and fifth place a Vettel, you know,
divide and conquer and conquered.
Went by both of them in the last couple fucking laps and ended up getting into
fourth place, which was fucking huge, you know,
and in a way fucked over the Mercedes team, you know?
And I bet they called them up and say, hey,
next time you fucking few chicanx want one of our fucking engines.
All right, we gave you one of our God damn engines. This is how you treat us.
You blocked the god Damn Ferrari's. Okay.
Get faster car out front.
Okay,
the fuck are we doing here?
I'll give you a fucking Volkswagen. Ngd You do that shit to me again. Right?
I get that must've happened somewhere along the line that that had to have
happened. So, um, is the highest team,
the American team. It's so fucking confusing.
I'm sitting here looking at McLaren, Honda, McLaren to me,
fucking worked on Mercedes and Honda used to dominate the sport.
Now this poor bastard, every time he goes around the fucking lap, dude,
it's like he's driving a hooptie that thing you shits the fucking bed every time
he took a fucking race off one, the one of those guys, Fernando Alonso,
I think you said, you know, fuck this, I'm going to go,
I'm going to take a race off.
That's how bad your engines are and I'm going to go drive the indie 500.
And I believe when he went there, his cause engine quit too. I'm not sure.
I've been flying all over to hell. All over the hell. All over hill.
So we went to the race, I got sunburned.
We saw all of this stuff do what we were sitting and we literally saw them pull
their cars in in the end where it was both Mercedes,
um, Hamilton and botox and then, um, Daniel Ricardo,
we saw them all shake hands. They walked up the stairs and then we saw them,
you know, on the podium we would like to the side, you know,
by the way,
okay.
That fucking trophy that you get for winning that race,
Jesus Christ and that,
that just one of the worst fucking trophies I've ever seen in my life.
Okay.
I think it's just the, the Toronto that the Toronto, the Canadian Maple Leaf,
they just sort of have it elevated with all this stuff,
but it's just such a blend.
They should make it like gold or something with, with the red outline of Canada,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
Red and white for Canada and then you put a bunch of gold in there.
You shine it up a little bit. Jesus Christ candidate,
all your imagination going into the Stanley Cup. I don't know.
I was really disappointed with it.
You know what's funny was the one that Lewis Hamilton, God was bad enough,
the one that Daniel Ricardo get, I swear to God,
he's probably using the proper open some door in his house.
That's how bad I gotta look this thing up. I really have to,
I gotta trash this fucking thing. Fuck is it?
Come on bill. Can you believe that cab driver? I deserve to be punished.
I mean that's the kind of mindset,
that's how I ended up driving a fucking cabinets. 70 years of age
and he's probably an immigrant.
People are fucking racist and they probably never get an opportunity.
I mean that's another thing, but that's, that's, that can happen to, you know.
All right, fair enough. Hey, fair enough. You know, who knows? Alright.
Montreal can I can,
I can add a candidate Grand Prix,
you know who's enjoying? Um,
okay.
Me Talking about this right now is, is Nashville Predator fence?
Cause the last thing, oh, maybe it looks a little bit bit,
it's got some fucking, it's got a little gold in there.
Okay.
Yeah, it's just sitting on like rebar. It just, just no imagination.
Let me, could you please put like a red outline around the gold?
Could you do something to fucking dress this up?
Um,
I swear to God if there's some fucked up reason I ever won that race,
I don't know. I got so into this game, this,
this fucking sport and I somehow lost 90 pounds so I could actually not be, uh,
you know, causing the car to lose.
And I somehow beat Lewis Hamilton in federal,
in a non Mercedes non Ferrari engine car.
If they brought that trophy out to me, you know,
and I just lost fucking five pounds pissing myself as I'm driving around the
damn track. I would, I just would be like, yeah, you keep that thing,
you keep it.
Why don't you go back and finish making that trophy and then I'll accept it.
I'm sure that wouldn't cause any, uh, any international incident.
Speaking of an international incident, what the fuck?
The Nashville predators, all the dreaded,
I lost sight of the puck and blew the whistle. Welcome Nashville Predator.
Have fans welcome.
You guys are now officially been baptized as hockey fans.
Okay. Up until now. You were expansion, expansion,
hockey fans. I didn't respect you. Even with your chance,
even with Mashville even know how far you've come.
I could not fully accept you as fans of the National Hockey League until I saw
your team in a Stanley Cup final score, a goal,
but the ref lost sight of the puck and it's waived off.
Now you've earned your stripes. Now you have a rough day. You hate.
You know now you got someone.
People are gonna send letters to and fucking make death threats and all the
other people take it too fucking seriously.
Can you imagine that poor fucking referee?
Listen to that Nashville Predator fan somehow figuring out his phone,
phone number. Yeah, buddy. Let me tell you what,
you fucking French mother fucker fired a kid. She would tear. See again,
I swear to God, I swear to God,
I swear to God buddy. I got some farmer and equipment.
I'll figure out how to unrest it just to run you over with that after I shoot
you the fucking face. I can't imagine the threats that he's getting,
like I shouldn't even talk about it. That's probably not even funny. I'm
unbelievable on fucking believable. But I told you guys,
I fucking told you I picked the penguins. I can think of have, I dunno,
somewhere around the first rounds, I know all these guys. Look,
I don't see anybody stopping it. I just didn't see anybody.
That's why I know after once the Blackhawks got knocked out, I was just like,
yeah, fuck that silver. They gonna win. And then I lost faith with him.
You know what their goal tending towards the end of the auto series.
And they proved me wrong. And then there was that game.
There was that game game for that, the predators one.
But that fucking look on Crosby's face when he scored that goal and he didn't
put his hands up. Like I scored a goal, he put 'em out to the side,
you know, gathering his fucking teammates and like,
that's one like total fucking business look on his face.
And um, congratulations to the penguins.
You fucking non-flying dirty birds. You did it again.
That's Crosby's third, that's Malkin start.
They now have one more than the fucking great duo of Mario Lemieux and Jaromir
Yaga. So that's, that's really saying something. And they got five [inaudible].
Okay.
They got fucking five. You know,
I don't want to start anything,
but they almost have twice as many as the fucking fly.
Twice as many as the flies. Philadelphia, you're going to sit there,
you're going to take that shit. You're going to have to, during the off season.
Same Way. Same Way I do as a Bruin fan. I believe we have six Stanley Cups,
but we've been around since like a Charles Lindbergh. So that's different.
Although the penguins have been around for 50 years already, just like that.
Who would have thought? Um, anyways, let's talk about old Billy.
No Fun. No Fun, Billy. What's the deal? No Fun,
Billy. Um,
so after telling you I was going to have no fun, um, you know,
it was my birthday. I was in Montreal, but even then I didn't go fucking nuts.
Like the last night we went to my favorite cigar bar up in Montreal.
We went to stogies and um,
I had a couple of fucking gray goose, even though I like Belvedere,
grey goose is the Pepsi of, of Vodka,
you know what I mean? I always like coke is code. Had the bite, you know,
give you a fucking right different, you know.
Okay.
Oh, speaking of that, what about Code Lotion?
Code Lotion of the week would have to be, they,
the Nashville predators scored a legal goal and the guy lost the fucking side of
the park. That is, that is,
that is NHL referee code right there.
That's exactly what the fuck that was. But um, yeah,
so I'm not a big grey goose fan. Um,
yeah.
You know, I feel like,
and I'm much like that cab driver that feels like he should be punished.
I feel like when I'm drinking that I should be feeling the effects of what I'm
doing to my body. I didn't want to watered down. You've got to drink the gas.
You know, I like Belvedere. It's got a little more of a kick to it. Uh,
although I'm not a big vodka guy, so I had that.
I fucking smoked a cigar after the race. 10 30. Oh,
freckles was in bed. Okay.
So when my alarm went off it five 30 in the morning from my early flight to get
back to my lovely wife and daughter, um, I was fine.
I was packed, I was ready to fucking go. Everything was fine.
And um,
okay.
But now it's official. Now back in, it's just like a, uh,
my big thing this year as a 49 year old is eight hours sleep.
I got to do it. I gotta do it.
Cause as much as I like going out and partying and doing all that Shit,
nothing at my age feels better than fucking eight hours sleep.
So I'm hoping that I can latch onto this lifestyle and have that be my new
fucking drug. Eight hours sleep.
Um,
wow.
Yeah, I got to do it. I don't know how to drink recreationally.
I gotta be honest with you. I just don't, you know.
Okay.
I just, if I'm doing it, I'm fucking doing it.
It's like I got into F1 now look at me.
I'm spending half the fucking podcast probably driving you guys up to Goddamn
wall talking about this shit. And now, you know, I went to my first race,
I'm going to the one in Austin and then immediately I just go,
well that's theirs. That's two down,
two down on the 20th I do two a year and 10 years I can fucking go to all of
them. You know, sometimes that works for me. Sometimes it doesn't, you know,
it works for me as far as like trying to succeed in life cause I just get into
something and I fucking do it. And next thing you know,
I crossed the finish line.
But you know when you apply that same sort of philosophy to uh,
drinking it, it doesn't work.
It's all about after you have the drink,
if you have the water afterwards and you sorta so be yourself back up again.
I don't know. I don't think I'm cut out for it. So I need to take,
I need, I've been needing to take time off for a good fucking year.
So that's what I'm doing right now.
I'm not saying I'm not going to drink for a fucking year, but I'm definitely a,
I don't know. We'll see. Be Funny if I end up in AA,
you know,
going to some fucking meeting. I'll never admit that I'm an alcoholic. Just got,
I'm going to go down and listen to those fucking stories, you know,
send me the stories. The stories are funny.
But then afterwards he's fucking chain smoking, doughnut eating, sad sex. I,
you know, I remember when I got busted for drinking and driving, one of the,
one of the crime ones, I had to go to two AA meetings.
I had to go to a mothers against drunk driving meeting and all this community I
had to do. And um, I remember going to the fucking,
oh, the fucking a meaning
Jesus Christ.
Just when you know, if you think you have an alcohol problem,
go to an AA meeting. Good Lord. These fucking people.
Holy Shit. Insane the fucking stories.
Waking up with no teeth.
Get bailed out of jail and fucking walking out with no shoes right across the
street to a liquor store.
Yeah. I mean, I don't know.
Maybe that's like an extreme version.
I don't fucking know. Where's a lots of this?
Let's read a little bit of advertising here for this week everybody. Huh? Uh,
where the hell is it? Where is it? Oh God,
somebody's going to correct me on Kryptonite this week.
Yeah,
you guys just don't fucking let up. Do you?
Okay.
Unreal. Last week quoted I guess the fucking super hero people,
they take it so God damn, seriously. All right.
I have advertising if this thing ever loads.
Come on, load it up. I never even finished talking about the cable shit.
I watched, you know,
I pay so much fucking money for the Internet and I pay so much fucking money for
cable and this shit doesn't work.
You know that the f one race didn't even record.
It started to record and it was just that shaking commercial that you can't fast
forward past because I wanted to see what happened at the beginning of the race
and then you know what? I went online and just found it.
So maybe that's what I need to do to do to do. I have no idea. Um, oh,
and I didn't even bring up the fucking Cavaliers. Holy Shit.
What a game. What a fucking game. 48 first quarter points.
86 points in the first half.
Unfucking believable and it was still,
it took them halfway through the fourth quarter.
That's how little competition there is. But you know something,
I think when that little fucking fellow there,
the guy shoots the three pointers, he's probably a foot taller than me,
but he looks like a little fellow on the NBA court when he fucking pretended to
take a shit.
That was one of the most classless things I've ever seen.
He pretends to take a shit and then runs up to court,
wipes his ass, and then wipes it on the cavalier logo. And then afterwards,
like, yeah, I was in the moment. I don't remember what I did.
Get the fuck Outta here. Get the fuck Outta here.
You don't remember what you do. You know exactly what you did.
Your fucking mind shitting on the floor.
I Dunno why, you know, I gotta hit pause.
I gotta hit pause to get the open this fucking thing.
Okay.
All right. I'm back. I'm back. Just went out the kitchen.
It's just saw my dinner. Salmon Salad with salmon.
Oh God. Fucking salmon.
It was a tragedy about salmon is how many salmon get killed a year.
It people don't even appreciate
it.
You know,
it's like tuna minus the personality. It's just like a fucking,
I was joking with Keith Robinson about that. We went out to dinners,
you know the fish option one was just salmon and he's just like, yeah,
Jesus Christ. And it's like, yes, salmon is salmon is a fucking Middle Act.
You know,
it's a fucking terminal feature of the fishing world. All right,
Luke crate everybody. Um,
be the envy of your friends and get your 100% exclusive rate. Oh,
exclusive crates@lukecraig.com slash burr and enter my code burr to save $3 off
on any new subscription. June's Luke crate theme,
his alter ego.
Luke crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a Finette fanatical fashionista than try loot wear.
Okay.
Monthly wearables and accessories with coke classics.
And your favorite franchises. If you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with even bigger Lu.
I have no idea what I'm talking about right now with Luke Craig dx offer expires
June 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific.
I'm just going to try and sound like I'm excited about this stuff and Jude's Lou
crate. You'll find items from Spiderman, transformers, the hulk,
and DC comics.
One lucky subscriber will also win a mega crate of seriously epic proportions.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM in case you forgot the fucking two sentences
ago,
Pacific time to subscribe and receive that month's crate and then the cutoff
happens. That's it. It's over.
You now as an adult cannot walk around dress like Spiderman.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing? I don't know.
Wow.
I Dunno.
Maybe you dress like Spiderman and you find some other nerd dress like wonder
woman and the two of you bang. Okay,
but how do you get your Dick out of that thing?
You've got to take the fucking mask off first,
right to Spiderman and pull it all the way down.
Shimmied over your fucking fat body. Uh,
go to Luke [inaudible] dot com slash burn enter my code birth to say $3 off on
any new subscriptions today. Ah, but it'll do two
[inaudible] look at that fat spider man do to to me undies me undies.
Each should go puke in the can.
I'm not recommending be an anorexic. Oh,
whatever that other one is where you eat and then you puke.
But if you balls as soft, you got on me undies.
Just don't puke down the front of them. Cause that would be disgusting.
Celine Dion's angelic pubic hair
of her dead husband. Sorry, that one just went off the rails. Me undies.
Everybody elevates your underwear game to the next level. Yeah. What's that?
What's that thing where you're eating then you puke?
Not anorexia.
Believe Mick element a tough one.
The undies Mian ds Dah de Bulemia do,
do, do, do me on these.
Me Mandy's fucking fuckers. Yeah.
Bulemia m and m could ride that word.
Bully Mia something.
Athenia I Renea Arenia I can, I can't do it a good thing I didn't remember it.
Alright.
[inaudible] elevate your underwear games to the next level with me on these.
You perfected your wardrobe. But what about the stuff not everybody gets to see.
Now we're not talking about your junk.
We're talking about the cloth that covers it.
If you've been settling for store-bought underwear, five packs,
I have something that will change your life for the better me undies.
What's the first thing you put on and the last thing you take off,
it's your underwear. Unless you Matthew mcconaughey.
Oh Him. It's probably his boots,
right as he steps out of a fucking Lincoln continental threatens junk hanging
out. Um, what am I make your,
your most important piece of clothing? The best it can be with me undies.
What is B undies? Oh, just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your fucking door.
Mandy's are designed in La and made from sustainably source micro modelle bottle
of fabric, three times softer than cotton. Where did it go?
The copy just went away. Biondi is softer than soft.
Luxury undies come in and an ever changing selection of classic colors,
bold shapes and adventures platforms.
So you can tailor your Andries to your own personal style.
I always stick with all the different colors and all this stuff.
That's what people like buy like sex swings, you know what I mean?
They just got to keep, you know, make it exciting. Um,
and guess what?
You can save time and money each month with a monthly subscription.
If you're not ready for the subscription, that's okay. You can still save.
That's because Mandy's is offering you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burpee you are and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead, revamp your underwear drawer. You deserve it. Once again,
that's beyond east.com/ [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] two more.
All right. Wince wink,
W I n C whiskey, India, November. Charlie,
when you have a great glass of wine, it enhances the moment.
Uh, you know what? You can't get drunk off of wine. Jesus Christ.
That's what they had at the Formula One.
They had Heinekens and then they had white wine.
I drank lives like I don't wanna get all fucking beer fat.
So I drank like two white wines and you know,
I now understand why so women are so many women that [inaudible] and to this it
possible to drink that shit and get any sort of a, a nice buzz.
You know, it's just another thing that's harder for women. You know,
you have no idea how difficult things are for us. Somebody write an article,
um, okay.
Whether you're reflecting on the day or with someone you love when you have a
great glass of wine, it intenses the moment. Wink understands this.
It's why they started their company to give you access to exceptional wines from
around the world. So you can have more of those moments. You know what?
I like a fucking Barolo. If you don't know shit about wine,
go to wink and get a Barolo. Get one that's a little fruity.
If that's the one I like and don't like those acidic once, um,
that's a nice one.
And then there's one that's sort of off the same vine begins with an N.
I can't remember Newbury street in Napoli. I don't fucking know. Ah,
just go to try, try,
try winc.com t r y w I N c.com.
Take a brief Palette profile, quiz and Winkle.
Re recommend distinct and interesting wines actually customized to your pallet
to be shipped directly to your door every month.
This is a great way to learn about wine, by the way, you know,
because it's a very intimidating thing.
I found that Barolo and I've stuck with that ever since then.
I haven't dared fuck with anything French or anything.
I would do this if I wasn't going to be a boring Billy here, Billy, no fund.
Uh,
none of your time is wasted fitting in to run to the store on your way home from
work on your way to an event or gathering. No more time spent, uh,
guessing what you might like because wink basis the wines they send you on your
Palate Preferences, wink,
we'll even introduce you to new rare and custom wines that are available outside
deals they've got a side deal here than not are not available anywhere else.
And tell you the story behind each one. Ah,
this you always gotta look for the side deal. That's a good side deal. You know,
who cares? They go to some local mom and pop pay. We'll use this as a rare one.
And uh, you give us a little doe, Ray, maybe we'll feature it.
Maybe you get into the fucking supermarket someday. You know,
that's a good deal.
And right now Winc is offering listeners $20 off your first order.
When you go to try winc.com/burger they'll cover the cost of shipping.
That's try Winc, spelled t,
R Y W I N c.com/burger to get $20 off your first order now,
plus complimentary shipping. Try
winc.com/burr they ought to have that for cigars. Wink. Why don't you do that?
Change it to stink. Uh, all right, stamps.com everybody last one.
I swear to God stamps, save you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business for the hassle of the post office and
mail everything from postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international. Great. Your stamp account. Lot of folk.
When I mail something in international Luna I terrorist create your stamp,
c stamps account and minutes online with no equipment to lease and no longterm
stamps.com brings all the services of the US Postal Service right to your
fingertips by imprint official us postage for any letter, any package,
any classic mail using your own computer and printer stamps.com makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale, automatically calculates the exact postage,
stamps.com leave and help you decide the best class of mail based on your needs.
I just don't feel like my needs are being fulfilled.
Sit Down Bitch. That's what stamped comp says and then he satisfies her.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter. We already said that.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm sending out my posters that I'm going to sell up to
my shows. I'm a more on if I can figure it out. So can you,
and right now you too can enjoy the stance.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm
commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone at the top of the home page.
You type in Burr that stamps.com enter bar. Ah,
right. So the cavs are playing tonight. Oh my God. Oh my God.
Dude. Can you imagine if they fucking win this one?
Then they going back to Cleveland. This is how quickly it can turn around.
This is how fast it can fucking turn around. It would be amazing.
I have no, I haven't enjoyed a fucking game in a long time like that. Um,
I was at a bar, of course. Who's kidding? Who? I haven't met Billy. No Fun.
I'd been Billy. Less fun today. Am I start Billy? No Fun.
MMM. [inaudible]
it's just the Cavaliers have to do what they did the other night again tonight,
you know, and then again, and then again. Uh,
but each game I think would be less. And then the, you know,
do you realize that the Cavaliers come back and do this?
They'd be the first NBA team to ever do it. And then secondly,
Steph curry taking a shot, miming taking his shit, wiping his ass.
And like does that one of the most classless fucking things you've ever seen in
your life? It's like fucking how that guy's a dad.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I don't understand. I don't, I, this just, it just makes me feel old liquid.
He does the no look pass and then he fucking eats.
He starts miming like, you know,
he has like binoculars on as he looks at the crowd.
Doesn't even look at the end of the, it's like, did Magic Johnson ever do that?
I just, I for the fucking life of me, fuck,
I will never understand that. That's like that dancing.
I told you when I was wet the game and there was some six year old kid dancing,
which should've been adorable,
but he had a look on his face like you wanted to beat the shit out of me.
I was just, I just don't understand what's going on with people.
Just a complete lack of class. And humility is, you know,
and this is coming from a drunk and even I'm noticing,
um,
anyways, a Kryptonite. Everybody, here we go. Let's do some of these, these,
these letters here. Hello, Bill. Hello Person.
Uh, I don't know. I know you don't give a shit,
but I refuse to stand by and watch you be an idiot. Uh,
but the story of Krypton is the planet x.
Last week I was talking about Kryptonite. I go,
isn't it like fucking natural to his planet?
How can superman be a allergic to a Kryptonite from his planet?
So this guy says,
Krypton the story of Krypton is the planet exploded from nuclear,
from a nuclear chain reaction. That's nice and vague from the family.
Big East caused by the planets,
UNCC unstable radioactive core. All right.
I guess that was a little more of an explanation.
Kryptonite being pieces of the radio active planet that somehow reach earth.
Okay,
well then shouldn't those things also affect the humans that go and get it?
Yeah.
You don't want, I mean, I don't understand that.
Oh, my phone's fucking rain. God dammit. Do I gotta take this?
Okay.
Oh, call him back. Um, okay. So that's what it is. All right.
So if the advice somehow got off earth and I went to Krypton and the earth
exploded,
they would then be our earth tonight and then superman could sit right next to
that radioactive rock. I know what this is. Some point you'd be like, Bill,
can you just fucking play along? Can you just play?
You know why I'm not playing along because this guy said I can't watch you be an
idiot. Watch me be an idiot. Like Kryptonite is an actual thing.
This is like, you think I'm an idiot?
Cause I can't name all the broads on sex in the city. I mean this is just fun.
It's a fucking, it's made up buddy. All right. Sorry.
I don't know. The origins of Kryptonite. What?
What does that gotten you in life?
Huh?
Other than a girlfriend with a retainer in her thirties. All right. Sex,
everybody. I see that people should be slower too.
I think that people should be slower to jump into bed. Friendship and respect.
Go a long way. Please have Nia in yourself.
Encourage young people to respect each other more before sex.
Um, listen, I don't give public service announcements. I mean,
I just complain about Shit. Look,
if you want to go on and get fucking let it go on and get laid. All right. Use,
use the use of fucking protection. But if you actually looking for somebody,
um,
you know, to have more than that, then you know, I think a,
a you something who I am so emotionally shut down. I,
I can't even speak on this. I don't know how I lucked out into beaten Nia.
It's just fucking happened. All right? But this, okay.
I just loved that somebody like this actually wrote in.
This is very conservative. This is really interesting.
I think that people should be slower to jump into bed. Friendship and respect.
Go a long way. Please have neon yourself.
Encourage young people's to respect each other more before sex.
Like how many listeners do I have my on my podcast at the Catholic church is now
trying to slip in public service announcements
will act week. Well, why don't I give everybody a southern accent?
I'm just gonna have the literally the pope in a southern accent say we'll after
we fucked all those kids. No one's listening to us. Um,
probiotics. Everyone. Hi Bill.
I was just listening to some videos on Youtube, on the youtube channel.
Bill burr archives. Not sure how long ago this one was from,
but you were asking for more information from anyone on how to get clean
probiotics. And I just wanted to say,
look up Kefir, k.
E. F. I. R.
Kefir is not only a racial slur.
I believe it's a racial slur in some country for a group of people
travel so much. I forget where that's frying. I looked that up.
I hope I'm not saying that wrong. Am I gonna have to fucking apologize.
Hang on a second. Camphor racial slur.
I spelled it like what they just said. Oh,
when my internet doesn't work, why won't you fucking work now?
Why won't you work?
Yeah. [inaudible]
yeah.
Oh, that's k. A. F. F. I. R.
The word Khafre is a term used in south southern of Africa to refer to a black
person. All right, let's see that. I knew,
I watched some sad show on how people treat each other.
So I must be saying that wrong. I'm going to say Kiefer, like Sutherland,
keifer.
You can buy the grains and you just add them to your organic milk milk and then
two days later
approximately you have key for yogurt.
Much better than the store bought ones because they get pasteurized and hence
you lose a lot of the bacteria. Okay. Cheers. Fuck face. Have a good one.
All right. But then what about the milk? Where do I get the milk?
I get the milk from an organic cow. And why don't I just lay off the booze?
Can I just do that? Would that be easier? Um,
alright lady needing advice.
Don't want to go to a male friend's wedding.
Oh this is great. I can give you advice on this.
My girlfriend's ex was gross lady needing advice.
Don't want to go to male friend's wedding.
My girlfriend's ex was gross.
I don't care. Okay. Hi Bill. I'm a 23 year old guy.
Yeah.
What the fuck is this? I think
the lady needing advice somehow got cut off. So this is a different one.
My girlfriend's ex was gross. Well, where's The lady needing advice?
Don't want to go to male friend's wedding.
I'll get to the bottom of that by Thursday. All right. Hi Bill.
I'm a 23 year old guy and I recently moved in with my 23 year old girlfriend.
Everything was going awesome until one drunken night.
She starts to tell me what her ex boyfriend was like.
Okay.
She explains that when she was 20 she dated this guy who will call Joe,
who is 11 years older than her, which already fucks with my head.
So being insecure the next day I decided to look him up online and he's
disgusting.
He's fat with an unkempt beard and really short in a pudgy face.
I just can't wrap my head around the fact that my girl being so hot and young
Banglaz Slob of a man picturing the two of the two together,
doing what we do now is really messed up messing me up to the point.
We stopped having sex a week ago. I just can't get it out of my head.
Uh, I mean, at one point, that disgusting mess really turned around Gross.
Am I just being an asshole? Do I break up with her? Honestly,
I just don't look at her the same way anymore.
I can handle her vast sexual history before me,
but not with that mess. It's really screwing me. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
All right, here's one of these things that if you were a woman,
they would be like, well, you have to honor that.
You have to know no means no. If you don't like this,
then you should honor that. That's what you're feeling and your partner,
if they really love,
you should understand this and wait until you're able to perform again.
But that's not how it works with guys.
You would be judged for being so fucking superficial and blah, blah, blah, blah.
So fucking superficial writing and the amount of young whores that I saw at
these old fucking guys at that F1 race, you know,
um, I don't know what you do to be honest with you, but I mean,
this is what I would do in the future. I wouldn't Google people. She used to,
fuck, that's probably a bad thing, but I'm thinking you're only 23 years old.
How did you know? So she used to fuck this troll probably under a bridge.
Yeah. That's kind of gross. Probably had some fucking one of those short,
but fat dicks know.
Yeah,
he cannot have his pubes. Oh, that's so disgusting. Um,
I would talk to her about it. I would just say, listen,
you know, I was insecure that you've,
that you were with an older man and was, you know,
not confident about what I was doing with you in bed.
And my curiosity got the best of me and I googled that guy, dude,
for all you know, you've got the wrong guy. By the way.
It might be someone with the same name. Who knows? Um,
you know, I don't know, but it's, I don't know.
In a week's time he can't get past that. I mean,
she's probably looking at you like you're a chimp. You're, you're,
that guy was a 34 year old fat, disgusting. Fucking,
you're 23 I'm imagining in shape. Right? Um,
I dunno.
I don't think it's weird that you looked at the guy and then all of a sudden you
just pictured and fucking your girlfriend. That's disgusting.
I don't think that's weird at all. Um,
women would say it is because they always defend each other for some reason,
yet they fucking go at each other like alley cats when we're not around.
Um,
I dunno, there's, I guess there's like some female like union, you know,
they act like union and men are not unionized,
which just every man from fucking self.
Yeah.
Um, although I am sticking up for you, so who knows? Um, yeah, I would a,
I don't know. I think I talked to her about it.
Just say it, you know, what do you think this makes me superficial?
She's going to be like, yes. I can't believe you judge me like that. Oh, I just,
I don't judge people on looks. I know you judge them on their wallets.
Um, if he has a nice personality and a private jet, you know,
I don't mind a little extra weight. Yeah. What was going on with deck guy?
Maybe that fat row was taken out to a nice restaurant every night so he could
keep her and that's how he got fat. I Dunno, you have a giant head too.
Most big fucking butcher block heads. Alright. Jealousy issues,
jealousy issues. Uh, dear Billy. Rosy cheeks. First off. I'm a huge fan.
Keep up all the great work. Anyway,
me and my girlfriend of four years just moved to France.
She is French and all our family is here.
We lived in Australia and planned to go back to Australia and 11 months.
Sorry. Had to get that yarn up. Our relationship is very serious.
We never laugh. No, I'm kidding.
I love this girl so much and plan on popping the questions soon.
A, we were at a local bar last night.
I'm not lingual enough to talk well at a bar yet,
so when we go out it's hard to follow what's being said.
But I still have a pretty good time after I had a few drinks with her and her
friends. This guy my girlfriend works with,
sits with us while it's just me and her about 3:00 AM and I immediately felt
bad. I had never met this dude, but when he sat down,
my girlfriend didn't look at me for 10 minutes and was 100% focusing,
focused on him, leaning in, laughing, et Cetera,
while I sat on my phone or looking up at the sports. Yeah, dude,
that's not good.
That's not good. Uh,
repeat that is not good.
I couldn't understand what they were talking about and there wasn't a way I
could be a part of it. I didn't like the way this guy was looking at me as well.
Twice during the time. After 10 minutes,
she struggly puts her hand on my knee and after five more minutes,
I tell her we should leave. I say goodbye to her friends and walk outside.
I smoke a cigarette and wait a bit longer.
Go back inside and she's still at the bar with this guy paying her bill.
Same Abiana says before, when we leave to walk home, I mean,
I'm immediately cold with her. You should have been.
She fucking embarrassed you. You absolutely should have been you.
Why you wouldn't do that to her. What'd Ya?
I was pretty drunk so I expressed my dislike for this situation in an overly
angry and an impatient manner. Yeah, you should've waited too. You is.
So this is one of these things, what you are right. And then you were drunk.
So then you became wrong. By the way. You said it,
20 minutes into a 30 minute walk home.
She was tearing up pretty bad and told me she was talking about me and other
harmless shit. Bull fucking shit.
She was talking about her dog and her dog was sitting next to it. She,
at some point you'd be like, look at his face. She would've done that.
She's full of Shit. This is my gut. Anyways,
well, the feeling stayed between us when we woke up this morning.
I don't get to socialize much here and I really liked this bar where everybody
goes to, but this felt particularly bad.
My girlfriend acts more natural in this country.
So this is awesome for her to be with her fellow countrymen.
But we've never in four years had a conflict where jealousy is an issue.
Have you ever had an issue where your girl's talking to a dude and it crosses a
line? Absolutely. Absolutely. And I was drunk and I said something.
Um, yeah and that didn't end well. Uh,
can I deal with this without affecting the relationship or how am I girl act
socially? Deep down. She's an absolute sweetheart and really sensitive.
So it's a bit delicate. Also, there's a part of me that says,
maybe it's all in my head. Anyways. Hope you can help bill.
Any advice would be great. Love to the birth family. Go Fuck Yourself.
All right, well there's so many factors. Yeah, you could be jealous,
but you know,
if it was actually 10 minutes and she didn't look at you and then I said,
I'll meet you outside. And she's still,
she's still in there talking to him about what a fucking great guy you are. Um,
you get some point to you. You, you got, doesn't lie unless your head's fucked.
All right? If it's coming from your gut,
if it's not coming from between your ears and it's all this fearful thoughts
that she had and you need to quiet that down.
But if it's coming from your gut and your judge guts just saying this just isn't
fucking right. Um,
and who's kidding who the French have different ideas about that type of shit
where, you know, I'm not saying everybody over there, but they, they,
they're the whole fucking having a Mitch mistress, you know,
is not looked down upon it seems sort of accepted. Yes. The resentment builds.
I don't fucking know, but um,
wow.
I, I just don't, uh,
that whole situation is bad and I actually think her reaching over and pat you
on the fucking leg to keep, to keep you at bay there. I even think that, that,
that makes it, that made it even worse. Um,
now having said all that, you should've waited till the next morning.
Yeah.
Or at least when you walk back, then I just say, listen,
I'm a little drunk right now, so I don't want to have a big conversation,
but I would like to talk to you about what just went down with that guy.
Yeah.
Like Dad ever works with a woman.
No, we need this guy. Yeah.
I think go is sleep knowing you're going to [inaudible] you know,
um, I don't know what the deal, who knows,
who knows what the fuck that was. I would be like,
alright,
so is she only
okay
the way she is? Because she's in my country and she doesn't know anybody,
but this is how she, this is how she really is.
Is this just a cultural thing that she used to fuck this guy and she psyched to
see him and this is going to be her little fucking fling on the side when we get
married. I would know what the fuck that thing.
Um,
but I would try to regroup and just be like, you know,
I find it hard to believe that if I was at a bar and I started speaking a
language with another woman that you didn't know and I didn't even look at you
for 10 minutes and then gave you a pandering pat on the fucking leg and then
tried. And then I went outside for a smoke and I came back in.
He was still in there talking to this person, this woman, if I was talking,
I'm saying if I was talking to this woman that I was somehow be able to convince
you that I was talking about you the whole time.
Okay.
I don't know what to tell you, sir.
Other than the practice up on your French practice up on your French and do it
without or knowing. Get that Rosetta Stone Shit.
Get your French game in order and learn all that [inaudible] 12 fucking,
uh, what's, what's ass over there? Gross. G, r o s,
something like that. You gotta know what the fuck he's saying?
Um, two girlfriends. So I don't know. I don't know what to tell you to do.
My Gut says that that was fucked up.
I could just tell you that I'm not trying to drive you away from this woman,
but that's, that seemed fucked up. If that was coming from you. Got Sir.
God Damn it, I would go with it. All right. That's it. That's the podcast.
If you enjoy this podcast and you'd like to donate without a caution,
he had dime. Just go to billboard.com.
Click on the podcast page and there's an Amazon link there.
Anytime you want to buy something off of Amazon, just go to my webpage.
Click on the link. I get credit for driving traffic to the website.
Doesn't cost you any more money. Whatever you were going to buy.
They kicked me a little fucking cash. Sheesh, or whatever. Fucking tidbits,
whatever they call those, those paypal money coin things. Um,
Brexit. I don't know what it's called. Um, that's it. Um,
that's what she can do. And if you don't want to do that,
I completely understand. I don't give a shit if you keep listening. You cheap.
Fuck. Alright, that's it. Go fuck yourselves. I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Let's go calves. Congratulations. Penguins.
My condolences to Nashville fans. Uh,
thank you to everybody at the Formula One race and um,
I can't wait to watch the next race. I don't even know where the hell it's at.
Uh, but I will be watching.
I actually finally watched the Italian Graham MotoGP. By the way,
trying to take those fucking races is so difficult. Every time I go to click,
it's the fucking moto three moto two. It's the fucking time trial.
I always got to click every single fucking one of them before I finally get to
the race. I got to see the Italian.
When these motherfuckers were going like 220 miles an hour on motorcycles.
And I finally figured out the kilometer thing.
Every 50 miles an hour is 80 kilometers.
So you just keep adding 80 every 50. So 5,100 miles an hour.
One 5,200 miles an hour is 81 62 40 a what the fuck would that be?
Three 20 roughly. All right. There you go. Piss a little metric system for you.
Go fuck yourselves. I'll see you on Thursday.